so I just first give a few opening
remarks before kick off the event so my
name is venkat guruswami I'm a senior
scientist here at the Simon's Institute
for the theory of computing and it's my
great pleasure to invite you all
um to the meet the fellows event for
summer 2023 the event has all other
events is also live stream so there'll
be people watching online also I hope
and just a brief introduction to the
Simon's Institute as you all know the
Simons Institute is the leading venue
for collaborative theoretical research
in theory of computing and related
fields
um it opened its doors in 2012 with a
very generous explanation from the
Simons Foundation which continues to
support us as the as the principal
um support donor and the programs kicked
off in fall 2013 so this is literally
officially sort of marking the end of
the 10th year of programs and I think
the Institute and the theory Community
should feel proud for the range of
amazing programs which The Institute has
hosted and all the people who have come
through and done great things to advance
the fields both in the core aspects as
well as for new connections and bringing
new problems and lines of inquiry so the
model of the Institute is that each
semester we have two long-term programs
focused on topical themes related to
Theory and other closely related fields
Each of which brings about 70
researchers Juniors and seniors to the
Berkeley campus and it's um you know
it's for a lot of activity and a few
years back we also started having summer
activity and summer programs in
particular uh and uh this summer we have
a program on analysis and TCS uh New
Frontiers and also a cluster on Quantum
Computing which will start in a couple
of weeks so so now we have year-round
Activity The Institute never sleeps it
seems and uh so it's my and today is
also a part of each of these semesters
we all have uh amid the fellows even
because one of the core and really
amazing aspects of these programs is the
junior fellows uh each of the program
brings in each program is about seven to
eight um you know post-doc Junior
fellows who come through and spend the
semester here and um and you know the
roster of people who have come through
is uh is amazing and they're they really
you know are completely key to the level
of activity uh in the program and so
we're really proud of the fellows who
come through and uh so we kick off this
each uh semester with the meet the
fellows even so where the fellows give
talks on what they're thinking about or
what they want to think about and also
as a way to just icebreakers and
introductions and so on okay and um so
that's this event uh today and uh we
have uh nine talks today split in uh two
sessions and so the first session we
have four talks and sort of loosely
themed um on analysis and how it helps
uh
um expansion and graphs and related
problems okay and
um so the first talk first Speaker we
have is Fernando germino and as a slide
really aptly illustrates
um you know Simon's uh Institute has
been a real uh you know so many people
pass through here on their Journey on
their academic journey in their initial
steps and uh so welcome Fernando and all
others
[Applause]
so um today I would like to talk about
expansion codes and optimization uh and
I'm Quantum at the Frontiers
so the goal is just we have only 10
minutes is to give a bird's eye view of
some of those areas right the errors
that I like so that you have some idea
of the things that I like that I had
been up to okay so it's going to be some
of the further talks are going to
developing some of those areas in much
more detail
um very good
and the what is expansion at a very high
level for me expansions are very broad
term that means some form of Randomness
or pseudo Randomness phenomenon and
there are many manifestations of it but
one that's very canonical and important
is in the study of expander graphs so
here on the left we have a graph that
combines the two properties of being at
the same time well connected but also is
parse the number of edges is very small
but somehow it mainly should be very
well connected and it resembles in many
ways as a complete a graph so this is
the notion of an expander graph right um
and then because it combines the two
very opposing properties of being sparse
and well connected we have lots and lots
of applications it's as if you you pay
little to have a very well connected
structure and you have lots and lots of
Publications and what are the canonical
questions that we ask in this in this
area uh one very important one is how we
pontify some the what are the forms of
expansion and how you quantify them
right if you go to graphs you have
several Notions vertex expansions Vector
expansion Edge expansion and now there
is even an emerging theory of what it
means should be a high dimension
expander a hyper graph expander later
and here we have links back to expand
there's topological expanders and so on
Notions affects fast mix and so all of
those are Notions of expansions that are
very important and once you have
established and Quantified some notion
of expansion you can ask for
implications what it means for algorithm
design what it means for hardness what
it means for complexity what it means
for combinatorics and you are not only
help with that you'd like to construct
those objects think about randomized
models think about our bright
constructions combinatorial ones and so
on right as so those are broad questions
that we ask about expansion right um
okay so let's switch gears let's go to
another area that I like that's called
interior and they're succinctly encoding
Theory study properties and algorithms
of robust collection of strings so here
the object is even simpler we have
execution there and we have a collection
of this whole space and any subset that
defines a code and cheaply for the code
we look at pairs of strings in the west
what is the Heming distance of them
right now we introduce some notion of
Jesus and the meaning one that the
periodies in the minimum realize the
minimum juices of the code and it
captures some notion of robustness of
the code okay but a code is nothing more
than any collection of
of strings very good and it leads to a
lot of very interesting mathematical
questions you have problems in script
geometry have Notions related to the
rayon where you complexity it's very
rich mathematically but at the same time
it can have very important Branch
complications to how we store
information how you communicate and so
on so it's very nice that you do our
theoretical work and it can lead to
the Publications and what is the abroad
question that we ask including Theory uh
one is we are very eager to understand
what is the best possible code for a
certain task that that's one of the
primary questions in coding Theory they
are General one and it's very surprising
that even for very simple tasks very
simple models the answer is that you do
not fully understand this and I think
that's very surprising even the level of
activities and once you have some idea
about the the ballpark of parameters of
the the good codes for a certain task
how you construct these codes right
that's a task that follows and how you
decode how you recover from the errors
so this is a
two very broad questions about coding
theory that we ask
now let's switch gear to optimization a
third area and here let's start we have
a linear program that we know that's
very powerful so you're optimizing a
linear function subject to linear
inequality constraints has lots and lots
of algorithms there is an extension to
it that's very powerful called Sim
program and here in very quickly semi
definite programming allows us to have
some form of quadratic constraints but a
relaxed form if you had quadratic
constraints of that form you'd have plus
minus one variables and that would be NP
hard to optimize so sdps that they
strike some sort of balance that we can
optimize efficiently but but it also
gives some flavor of quadratic
constraints very good
and on top of that you can create larger
and larger programs you can create hiatx
on top of linear programs on top of sdps
one very nice hierarch is the sum of
squares has to be hierarchy that's very
useful it can even do koshish bars
automatically for us but it's very nice
and the those tools in conflicts
programming they capture not everything
but they capture a lot of what we know
for efficient computation a lot of our
efficient algorithms can be guessed as
complex optimization algorithms okay
we are very curious to understand the
boundary between what can be done
efficiently and what becomes hard or
what is interactable so you're trying to
delineate this boundary and the
optimizations certainly helps a lot
delineate these boundaries if you design
an algorithm using LP stps or hierarch
it becomes fast if you have a very
powerful Hiatus like sum of squares and
you show a lower bound against it we
have some evidence that the problem may
be hard okay very good so that that's
the optimization part let's switch gear
show another topic Quantum Computing and
then if the laws of Nature's tell us
that at a fundamental level we have
quantum mechanics why not use this for
computation in our favor right so the
computation based on quantum mechanics
this is a nutshell Quantum Computing
okay and then one very important
phenomenon that happens in Quantum
Computing is in quantum mechanics and so
on is this notion of a Quantum
correlation it's a super classical form
of quantum correlation that's known as
entanglement a lot of the extra power
that comes in the quantum model comes
from integral comes from the super uh
the strong form of correlation but it's
very mysterious you do not understand
fully what it can be done with that and
then so on so it's natural to ask what
somehow is the complexity of
entanglement and what are the
implications of entire movement for for
several Fields so in terms of complexity
we have a class called qma2 a
generalization of NP with two grooves we
have the celebrated Quantum PCP
contracture in terms of implications we
have implications for algorithm design
condensed matter and so on and so forth
okay that's a Quantum Computing part and
we mentioned these fields somehow in
isolation right we said that we have
explanation codes and optimization and
Quantum but there are a lot of synergies
among these areas so if you take for
instance expansion and codes a lot of
codes that they are constructed using
expanded graphs or high dimension
expanders and so on so I have a lot of
synergies there uh another one is
expansion of optimization and I think
natal is going to talk more about that
so if you have good Notions of expansion
sometimes you can approximate some csps
because of the expansion very good uh in
terms of quantum and code we need to
make Quantum computation robust
situators right so we have Notions of
quantum quotes very good we also have we
can use optimization to understand this
Quantum correlation disentanglement okay
and create that sap higher option
understand those we can combine
expansion codes and optimization to
create the codes for almost optimal
codes we can use uh codes and
optimization can use optimization to
understand the best parameters for codes
okay and the expansion in calls there is
even something that's called a Quantum
expander so there are lots and lots of
connections there very good and if
you're not satisfied you can even refine
that right in terms of expander codes
you have super spinning codes and is it
realities and so on we have celebrated
results like your IPS who should be
space we have qme2 and so on and and
this list goes on and on
so we have a decoding algorithms based
on on some of squares and so on we have
LP High Erics to understand bounds and
codes
very good and then you refine these you
have fast algorithms to enter the
compositions algorithms are in the games
pcps and so on and so forth so lots and
lots of synergies and you could refine
this list uh for every rate there are
many beautiful results around uh these
interactions very good
and if you're interested in
collaborating please let me know and you
can get this stuck on a nice open
problem together and then that's uh all
that I want to say thank you very much
for your attention
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah what are quantum extenders
yeah yeah it's it it has a flavor of a
user expander it's a super operator if
you have an instrument it's like that is
fighting at Quantum State and you you
have the the identity the normalized
version of identity that behaves like
that one's Vector so Quantum expander
does not into this that is identity
operator but everything that you're
talking about related shrinks in for
business form so it's very much like an
expander there's a super operator that's
excellence
any other questions about the other
three areas
oh okay
thanks for that thank you
[Applause]
I guess we'll just keep going yeah
thank you
[Music]
all right so in the first talk we
already saw uh connections between
expansion and optimization and one facet
where the connection is very deep is the
complexity of the unique games problem
and how expansion affects the
approximation complexity of that and
metallic buff now
thanks venkat so hi everyone I am a
postdoc at CMU and I'm visiting Simon's
system uh this summer for the analysis
program
so I'm broadly interested in
combinatorial optimization some of
squares algorithms and high dimensional
expanders and today I will give you a
teaser into my recent Works in these
areas that study the unique games
problem
so consider a system of satisfiable
linear equations module okay
where each equation only depends on two
variables and is of the form x i minus X
J equals aij module okay
so the natural question is how do we
solve this linear system
and a simple answer from kindergarten is
to use gaussian elimination
but in this case we have an even simpler
algorithm
just create the following graph
where you put in a Vertex for every
variable and an edge for every
constraint and label the edges by a by
the right hand sides
now assign an arbitrary label to the
first vertex propagate the value
using the edge one two to the second
vertex and so on until you have a
solution to all the vertices
this problem is called unique games and
unique because given a value to the
first vertex there is a unique value to
the second vertex that satisfies The
Edge one two
and so now let's think of this alternate
graph view where we create different uni
Games instances on G by varying The Edge
labels
so now what if I tweak the problem a bit
and give you a instance where only 90 of
the equations are satisfiable
can we still find a 90 satisfying
assignment
or what about just a one percent
satisfying assignment
note that a random assignment satisfies
One by K fraction of the equations but
we are thinking of K as very very large
so this is not good enough
thank you
in 2002 code conjectured that in fact
this is not possible
given a 90 satisfiable instance you
can't even find a one percent satisfying
solution efficiently
and unique games is in fact at the heart
of our understanding of approximation
algorithms ever since it was proposed
researchers continue to discover
reductions to problems
where the results were such hardness of
approximation results are not known
under uh NP not equals p
and not just that in algorithms it's a
great test spread for new ideas
so let us see what's known for The
Unique games problem
so the history of this problem is really
a cat and mouse game between hardness
and algorithms
right after it was proposed there were
many algorithms that tried to refute the
conjecture but they only managed to give
K dependent guarantees
then very surprisingly it was shown to
be easy on expandergraphs or random
instances and even shown to have
non-trivial sub exponential time
algorithms
on the hardness side it was shown to be
hard on a larger class of graphs called
small set expanders under a stronger
conjecture
and then very recently to culminate all
these results
uh a breakthrough series of works showed
that 49 versus one percent unique games
is NP hard
interestingly all these algorithms are
based on rounding semi-definite
programming relaxations and in fact a
special class of them called Summer
squares
uh but even though these methods are
really powerful our understanding of
these algorithms are stuck in the worst
case
so uh our works significantly expand the
class of instances uh where ug is easy
and build new rounding techniques for
sum of squares and as a consequence we
provide a response to these two
complexity results
so we give algorithms for ug on these
scary looking classes of graphs
and the um
uh these include many graphs that you
might have heard of such as noisy
hypercube and high dimensional expanders
but for today let me just focus on the
easiest uh graphs called I mean which
are expanders
so recall the definition of expansion
the expansion of s is uh the orange Edge
is divided by the orange plus green
and G is an expander if all sets of size
0.8 n have expansion roughly 0.2
the first works on unique games showed
that ug is easy over expanders
and we give we start by giving a new
analysis for this result
so our key observation is that given a
ug instance on G
which is 90 satisfiable two solutions
for this instance which satisfy 90 of
the constraints must actually be equal
in most of the vertices so we call this
uniqueness because uh basically there is
one solution and every other solution is
a perturbation of this solution
so why is this property even useful
uh that I will briefly tell you about
some of squares
so uh the summer squares algorithm is a
powerful meta algorithm based on
semi-definite programming really it's a
hierarchy of relaxations graded by
degree
where as you go up the hierarchy your
time taken to solve the relaxation
increases
and sum of squares has been very uh
successful in the average case setting
especially for robust statistics
and in fact all these algorithms rely on
uniqueness property of the solution
space and they convert such a proof of
uniqueness into an algorithm but this
despite the success very less is known
in the worst case uh setting uh like
yeah and this is mainly because
uniqueness is too much to expect
so we relax this property to weak
uniqueness
so the uh Pros are that now it can be
shown to hold for worst case problems of
Interest
but we uh but the average case
techniques no longer apply
so with this background uh
we can firstly
convert this uniqueness property on
expanders to get a solution
and uh
for our classes like for more
generalizations of expanders we can use
analysis techniques to show a weaker
uniqueness properties in the first case
we can show like a weak uniqueness and
the second case we show that there can
be only a few Solutions
uh yeah
so now let me end with some future
directions
uh
so finding um getting hands on hard
instances for Unique games has been an
intriguing open problem and progress on
this was mainly stuck because we do not
have any candidate graphs that should be
hard
so the upshot of our result with
combined with the previous hardness
result
is that a particular class of graphs is
likely hard for uh 49 versus one percent
unique games
and a good open problem here is to can
we convert this evidence into hardness
for sum of squares
and what about 99 versus one percent can
we show hardness for summer squares
uh on the Johnson graph
so more broadly thinking of
approximation algorithms in general what
are other optimization problems with
such uniqueness properties
uh I would like to end with this picture
um firstly for many of so firstly for
all of these problems the best algorithm
is the degree two sum of squares
algorithm so the natural open question
is can we use higher degree sum of
squares
uh
what about getting better approximation
algorithms for these problems and in
some exponential time
or for problems such as graph coloring
where there is a huge gap between
algorithms and hardness
thank you
[Applause]
questions
could you say something about what you
meant by the Johnson graph is likely
hard for 49ers
I mean look at the reduction so we give
algorithms on these globally hyper
contracted graphs
um which include Johnson graphs in a
certain parameter regime but if you
tweak the parameters a bit then you get
to like our algorithm no longer works
and you also when you look at the
hardness result
or you can say like it is it is complete
the hardness reduction is pretty
complicated but we can kind of point out
the source of the heart
do we know if you can yet if you can
apply this sort of thing instead of
affine games
of course I don't like so much special
time algorithms that feed the
once this ratio for like
so yeah currently I think we only know
it for your lead games uh we have
something unique games and small set
expansion
so yeah that's the open version that
whether you could give it for other
Downstream problems
[Music]
you'd expect
like why should you expect that being
playing one percent
I think the strongest evidence is this
hardness is that which is 49 versus 90.
so maybe I have a quick question versus
one person we do know SOS gaps right
just by checking through the reduction
yes do those instances at all anything
like Johnson craft for today yeah let's
put uh I wanted to answer that's those
instances are like basically like the
Johnson
s we now know that Craftsman is easy so
the hardness is
wait wait do you say you're saying that
these glass have like a one versus 49
gap for SOS but actually not a one
versus 99 exactly yeah yeah so uh this
is like evidence that Johnson should
even probably be hard for 99
I mean it would be nice to get such a
some
or something so yeah there could be one
person there could be yeah so that's
open it's open even for like four runs
or something yeah
any other questions
okay great thank you
[Applause]
okay
right so let's continue so our third and
I guess final talk on this expansion
series but now the high dimensional
version Max Hopkins will tell us about
htx and friends thanks hi I'm Max I'm
from UCSD really happy to be here at
Simon's for the summer I'm going to talk
about high dimensional expenders and a
number of related areas in TCS
um but you know to make things easy
we'll just focus on three areas I'm not
going to cover uh all all five that are
listed here but if you're interested in
any related areas please come talk to me
I love talking about all of these things
um so to start off I should probably
tell you what a high dimensional
expander is we've already heard about
expanders a little bit
standard expanded graphs are basically
sparse models for the complete graph
sparse graphs that have these amazing
robust connectivity properties like the
complete graph there are a number of
different ways to Define them we'll
actually see one explicitly in a couple
of slides
High dimensional expanders are roughly a
family of generalizations of these
Notions to hypercars and other extended
settings like Grossman and post sets and
chain complexes but we'll focus on the
simplest setting of hypergraphs here
um in particular I'll focus on a special
case that I think is still very powerful
which is the theory of partite spectral
High dimensional expanders so as a brief
reminder a bipartite graph is just a
graph with two sides usually L and R
here so that we can generalize a written
Omega 1 and omega-2 and the graph has
edges going between the two sides and we
can think about the graph just being as
a subset the edges as being a subset of
the Cartesian product of Omega one and
Omega two this is easy to generalize to
D Dimensions right I'm just going to
have a departite hypergraph that's a
subset maybe a weighted subset if you
want of the D wise Cartesian product of
D different face uh
domains Omega one through Omega d
okay one way that I like to view this
which is sort of an analytical view of
expansion that I'm stealing in a sense
from works of diction and dinner and
girl lift shits and blue very beautiful
Works
um I can always view a bipartite graph
instead as like a joint distribution a
particularly in the graph case is the
two-dimensional joint distribution over
this Cartesian product where the
equivalent is I draw a random Edge from
the graph and this gives me something
you know one coordinate on the left side
and one coordinate on the right side so
I can equivalently view this as a
distribution and when do I say that a
graph is an expander well roughly we'll
call G and expander when this sort of
two-dimensional distribution in
expectation acts like a product acts
like a two-dimensional or a two-fold
product in the sense that if I take a
function on the left side of my graph F
and a function on the right side of the
graph G and I look at the expectation of
f times G it decorates into the product
of the expectations
you know if I were actually a product
this would be exactly true on an
expander this is true up to some error
term in L2 Norm so this is an equivalent
way to define what's called spectral
expanders
and I think this leads to a very natural
extension in in D dimensions
uh so now we have you know Adida a
departite hypograph
which corresponds in the same way if I
draw a random Tuple do a d dimensional
joint distribution over these spaces X1
through XD when do I call x a high
dimensional expander well again when it
acts like a d dimensional
in what sense uh well there are a couple
ways you could reasonably Define this
here's the one that we'll take and
that's actually equivalent to what
you'll hear called local spectral
expansion typically
will require that if I pick any two
variables from here x i x j and I look
at the marginal of this distribution
that I want this to satisfy this
property I want it to be an expander and
moreover that's actually not quite
powerful enough for your want in a
product space if I like condition on X1
being some value everything else remains
independent so I actually want this to
hold under conditioning as well I want
to say that if I look at this marginal x
i x j and I fix some other number of the
of the domains like I fix X1 to be 5 and
then I look at the conditional
Distribution on x i x j this should
still be an expander it doesn't have to
be totally independent but still it
satisfies a sort of decoration property
and expectation so that's going to be my
my definition of apartheid High
dimensional expanders
um okay so now I want to talk about sort
of the first connection here which is
with the field of Boolean function
analysis I'll be very high level the
classical theory of Boolean function
analysis and TCS basically studies the
behavior of Boolean functions functions
on the hyper queue with respect to
certain operators or you can think of
them as graphs markup chains things like
the hypercube graph where I take a
string of retina bits and I flip one bit
uniformly at random or the noise
operator which looks at like noise
stability of functions is something
that's studied a lot where I flip each
bit with some independent probability
and these have been a very powerful set
of tools both within analysis of course
but also in hardness of approximation
extremo combinatorics many areas
throughout TCS but they're a little bit
restrictive in that they only talk about
functions whose domain is the hypercube
and sometimes we're interested in
domains that aren't the hypercube and
there's been a lot of interest in this
recently in fact even sort of
classically in the 90s this original
Theory only really works for the uniform
distribution over the cube and it turned
out to understand the theory of like
sharp thresholds for graph properties
and monotone functions we needed analogs
of these type of analysis on the biased
Cube which which acts differently
um and beyond that much more recently in
hardness of approximation there was this
result that Natalie mentioned called the
two to two games conjecture or this like
49 versus one percent unique games
result and this relied exactly on an
analog of hyper-conjunctivity something
called Global hypercontractivity uh on
the Grossman which is some Subspace
version of these objects and and this
led to the proof of the two few games
conjecture so these sort of extended
domains I think are of great interest
both within analysis and the rest of TCS
which leads of course to a natural
question
generically what sort of domains do we
expect we own the cube to satisfy this
type of theory of analysis and and
broadly we don't have a great answer to
this up until this sort of recent line
of works we really had like three or
four examples of this uh this plus maybe
the multi-slice and products and a
couple other things
So unsurprisingly based on the name of
the talk and the slide up here probably
you guys can guess what comes next which
is that high dimensional expanders do
provide at least sort of the starting
steps to a general theory beyond the
queue hopefully the way that I Define
High dimensional expanders in the last
slide should make it clear that the cube
is a high dimensional expander right the
cube is an example of a product space if
I restrict on things they're all
perfectly independent this is this and
more generally products are a very
special case of the theory of high
dimensional expanders and over the last
six or seven years this theory has been
developed and said you know not only can
we express products in in this more
relaxed way but also much of the theory
of Boolean analysis actually does Port
over to these objects that we have I
haven't written in here but we have
foyer compositions we've proved recently
things like analogs of hyperconductivity
and small set expansion this very
powerful set of tools on products
um and I think Beyond sort of just
giving a little bit more of a general
understanding of when this type of
technique works one thing that I think
is very interesting and very exciting
about this type of analysis on high
dimensional expanders is that HDX can be
very sparse in a way that products can't
be and hopefully in the last minute or
so of the talk I'll mention why this
might be a powerful thing to have as
like a gadget in a type of hardness
reduction
okay so but I don't want to just say
that high dimensional expanders have a
role to play in Boolean analysis so I
think this is true I also want to sort
of talk about the reverse implication
that I think studying questions in
Boolean analysis leads to interesting
questions in the mathematical theory of
high dimensional expansion in particular
what we've sort of found in this work on
analysis is that the current theory of
spectral High dimensional expansion
it works well for problems where I can
admit some sort of L2 error that it's
okay to have some sort of error scaling
with the two Norm of the functions that
I want and if I just want to prove like
spectral bounds on the noise operate you
know de-randomizations of the noise
operator or certain special cases of
hypercontractivity this works it's it's
okay but it doesn't seem to work for all
problems there are more sort of delicate
higher Norm type behaviors where having
this sort of L2 error seems to be really
a significant problem things like
generalized cyber contract PDQ
hyperconductivity I won't say exactly
what these are but they're sort of more
delicate higher Norm Properties or more
involved characterization theorems like
the analog of the hoons
these don't seem to play very well with
current definitions of high dimensional
expansion and I think in particular this
suggests to me a really interesting new
definition of HDX that we should study
that says well if this two Norm sort of
isn't powerful enough
what if we said we'll call a a departite
hypergraph a high dimensional object a p
Norm expander if the marginals look like
a product with error scaling with P Norm
instead of with two norm and you know of
course things like products will satisfy
this since they're perfect but you know
even if I take like dense random subsets
this should work out but there's a
completely open question that says are
there sparse families of objects that
are P Norm expanders we know this for p
equals to two and I would conjecture
that the sort of famous classical
constructions we have what are called
the ramanujan complexes of lubazzi
Samuels and Dishnet that are sort of
perfect high dimensional expenders
should satisfy this type of property for
pbons two and that this should also lead
in turn to interesting properties in
analysis
um
okay let me spend like one or two
minutes talking about hardness of
approximation
and then I'll wrap up so uh hardest of
approximation and Analysis also
classically have a lot of interplay
between them I want to talk about how
HDX plays or could play a little bit of
a role here in particular I'll talk just
about a core Paradigm called agreement
testing
in particular a direct product test so a
direct product test will think of as a
pair of like a domain a deep outside
typograph or Simplicity think of it as n
to the D and an algorithm that tests of
a given function on the domain makes
like o of one queries to the function
and tries to test if it's a direct
product if if the value of f on this D
Tuple is actually just the Cartesian
product across D functions G1 through GD
on each coordinate
um
and we'll assume that any DP function
passes the test for for Simplicity this
type of test has two main parameters you
can look at the Domain size the size of
XD and we can look at the soundness
which is basically the smallest
probability where if my test passes I
can actually infer something about the
function so if if the probability of my
test passes is greater than Delta this
should tell me that f is indeed close to
a direct product in some sense
um at a high level why would I care
about these two things well if I somehow
wanted to use this type of test in a
hardness reduction which is where it's
classically used you can think of XD as
being this is sort of the size of the
gadget that we're using and it will
correspond to how much it blows up to
the instance so if this is super
polynomial you're not going to get a
polynomial time reduction so we really
want to keep this sort of as small as
possible on the other hand we want this
soundness to be small this is going to
correspond to like the Gap and hardness
that you get at the end of the day the
integrality Gap sort of how hard the end
instance is
so what's known here well it turns out
uh that almost everything is open in
this type of question we don't have
optimal DP tests and in fact to my
knowledge we really only have like two
or three versions of this test that have
subconstant soundness we only recently
learned that on the full product space
end of the D that you can get sort of
optimal soundness something that scales
inverse exponentially with Dimension
there's a you know the problem here is
now that the size of this is n to the D
so if I set D to be super constant I
won't get a polynomial size instance
there's a beautiful D randomization of
this based on subspaces uh due to
impognets and victorson that's
polynomial size you can use it for this
type of result and indeed it's been used
later to build pcps but you lose
exponentially in the soundness the
soundness becomes one over poly D and
this ends up giving you poor parameters
at the end of the day of your reduction
and I'll mention that sort of famously
High dimensional expanders do support
this type of agreement test but only
when your soundness is really high when
it's like 99 which is a very different
regime uh and not as useful for this
type of uh trying to build strong gaps
in in hardness of approximation and I'll
just mention maybe as the final thing
that you know I do believe that HDX have
a role to play in sort of this much
smaller one percent regime and we have a
little bit of uh progress on this
recently uh with dick chain we showed
that certain dense high-dimensional
expanders do give rise to more General
families of DP testers with optimal
soundness so this will apply to things
like the full linear metroid or other
types of sort of dense uh expanding
objects and I think what's exciting
about this is that there aren't they
don't seem to be inherent barriers to
extending this to polynomial size
families and to try to get a test that's
both polynomial size and satisfies
optimal sadness this seems like a
possibility and something that we're
working on
I think I'm basically out of time the
other direction just says I think it's
very interesting in HDX to look at
polynomial size families typically the
theory of high dimensional expanders
people look at really linear size things
in constant Dimensions that seems to not
be the regime that's really important in
hardness of a prox and I think it leads
to a lot of interesting questions
thanks so much okay great thanks Max
[Applause]
you can have a question well next week
of sets up
yeah please
these Notions this like denorum HDX does
this have similar like local properties
um
to some extent but things like I don't
know how to prove trickling down for
Vietnam
there's some things like the mixing
in some sense you can get like versions
of local mixing implies uh like local
peanut mixing implies Global P Norm
mixing but I don't know how to get all
the results it's a good question
the product uh
I think that there are lower bounds
saying you can only get one over
polynomial softness with two queries
even on like the full product
okay
like when I said like whatever sound is
it where you can get you can still get
it in the product right yeah yeah yeah
yeah of course yo I mean the ACs will
never have better it's not less than a
product you're trying to de-randomize
the size of the instance and keep the
same size
specification of HDX to help
uh because you want to keep polynomial
size in your reduction you're using
these as like a gadget in your you know
you start with a sad instance and then
you blow it up into these you you encode
it into some outer PCP then there's an
error inner test which if you use like
an entire product would blow up the size
Beyond a polynomial size reduction so
you're trying to keep the blow up of the
instance for your reduction
uh again let's take any other questions
offline thanks and the last Talk of the
session uh this Quantum was a classical
query in communication and uh also
highlighting for the analysis the team's
program
thanks I'm good uh I'll be talking about
a few cool results in Quantum versus
classical separations inquiry and
communication
and I'll tell you a little bit about the
role of Fourier analysis in these works
so quantum computers are widely believed
to exponentially outperform classical
computers but there are very few
settings where we can prove this
unconditionally
communication complexity and query
complexity are two striking examples of
such settings where you can prove
exponential speed UPS
interestingly many state-of-the-art
separations in these two models actually
rely crucially on Fourier analysis in
particular Fourier growth bonds
so what are Fourier growth bonds they
refer to Upper bounds on the level K
mass of a function
by the level K mass of a function we
mean the sum of absolute values of
Fourier coefficients of size k
so it's the L1 Norm of the level K
Fourier coefficients
it's not going to be important to
remember what this concept is but it's
very easy to describe and it's a very
natural concept and it's been well
studied in the context of
pseudorandomness and learning theory
we're going to see some applications of
Fourier growth bonds to Quantum versus
classical separations
here analysis has been used a lot in
understanding Quantum versus classical
but one of the most notable examples of
this is the Oracle separation of pqt and
pH by Ron Ross and abhishekal
so this was a breakthrough result they
solved a major open problem in Quantum
complexity Theory
it showed that a rather weak model of
quantum computation can exponentially
outperform a rather strong model of
classical computation when it comes to
certain tasks
this can also be viewed through the lens
of query complexity and it says that
Quantum query Protocols are more
powerful than ac0 circuits
and this is the best qualitative
separation that we have in the query
complexity world
and the Heart of this result was Fourier
analysis
so what they showed was that upper
bounds on the Fourier growth imply lower
bounds for the formulation problem
so this correlation problem is a
well-studied problem that's easy in the
quantum world
and these works showed that if your
Fourier growth is small then you cannot
solve the correlation problem
given any model of computation if you
can show that it has small Fourier
growth then this model cannot solve the
correlation problem
the all had already proved that ac0
circuits have small Fourier growth and
as a result it followed that ac0
circuits cannot solve the formulation
problem whereas Quantum query protocols
can solve this
so this works this line of Works shows
that showing that correlation is hard
for a model essentially reduces to
proving Fourier growth Fourier growth
Bonds on that model
this was the starting point for many
lines of works that showed newer and new
and classical Quantum separations using
Fourier growth
I'll talk about one such line of works
and this is about optimal separations
so this problem asks given a Quantum
query protocol
how many classical queries do you need
to simulate it in the worst case
what is the exact blow-up you have from
Quantum query complexity to randomized
query complexity
this was asked by Aarons in a number is
in their original paper on for relation
and in a recent series of works this was
resolved
We Now understand what is the exact blow
up when you go from Quantum query
complexity to randomized query
complexity
and a lot the authors of these works are
actually participants of this talk so
you can talk to them to know more about
these
so loosely speaking these Works show
that if you want to prove optimal
separations between Quantum and
classical you really need to understand
optimal Fourier growth bonds
so now let me tell you about some of my
follow-up works
so one of the things we do is we take
this optimal separation and ask how can
we improve it
well one thing you can do is to give the
classical model some additional power
so we give the classical model the power
of parity queries and we ask can we
still prove the separation if so what is
the optimal separation
it turns out that in this context parity
queries don't help at all that is
whatever was the separation before it
continues to be the optimal separation
even if the classical model can make
parity queries
and it turns out that this relies on
understanding the optimal Fourier growth
of these parity query protocols or
parity decision trees and that is what
this work does
so now I'd like to switch tracks from
query to communication
so what do we know about communication
separations
so this has a long history of work
spanning over two decades and there are
many examples where Quantum outperforms
classical
and the state-of-the-art separation you
know prior to our works was the
following
it's not important what these models are
but again it shows that a rather weak
model of quantum communication can
exponentially outperform a rather strong
model of classical communication
this was proved by gavinsky and it's
subsumed most of the previous operations
it turns out that you can prove you can
pretty much recover the separation using
Fourier analytic techniques
in particular we use the formulation
problem and Fourier analytic framework
to recover this separation
and this result has some additional
properties that are nice for the quantum
protocol that I'm not going to describe
but what's interesting is that you can
take this framework in the query
complexity world and lift it to the
communication complexity world to prove
state-of-the-art separations
there are a couple of other nice things
that you can do with this framework
for example you can prove xor memos
Loosely speaking we say that the
complexity of solving K independent
distances of the same problem is K times
as hard in the sense that the advantage
of solving the xor of K copies decays
exponentially in k
these kind of results are very hard to
establish in general but for the
formulation problem and for this model
we're able to do it using the Fourier
analytic framework
another cool application is to prove
lower bounds against models that have
limited Quantum Resources
so we take classical models and give
them the power of some limited Quantum
Resources
for example we can give Alice and Bob
access to a limited number of epr pairs
or we can all of them to commune
communicate a few qubits of quantum
communication
and we ask can we still prove a
separation is there any Quantum
advantage over such classical protocols
with limited Quantum Resources
and it turns out that indeed you can
if you have any classical model and you
give it a certain number of Quantum
Resources
giving it slightly more Quantum
Resources is going to give you
exponentially more speed
this is in contrast to the situation of
public Randomness where login bits of
Randomness suffice for every task on the
other hand for entanglement such a
situation does not hold
and this is also approved using Fourier
growth and we study Fourier growth of
protocols that have a limited amount of
Quantum Resources
so this Fourier growth technique is
actually fine-grained enough to separate
models with slightly more Quantum
Resources and slightly less Quantum
Resources
I'd like to mention in ongoing work with
a very nice open question
and this is about understanding the best
quantitative separation between Quantum
and classical in the communication world
were actually very far from
understanding the answer to this
question
but we are able to improve the
qualitative the quantitative aspects of
some of the previous separations
this really requires understanding
Fourier growth of communication
protocols Loosely speaking there's a
very nice open question here about
Fourier growth as communication
protocols that I can talk about in the
open problem session
so let me conclude
living many new developments in Quantum
versus classical separations especially
in query and communication complexity
and Fourier growth bonds play a key role
in these separations
can we discover new Quantum versus
classical separations perhaps using
Fourier analysis
thank you
[Applause]
say something about the asterisk and all
the quantums simultaneous yeah so the
Aztecs they know that the players share
intended them Allison in 10 minutes
yeah
so what is
randomized
so Alice and Bob should only communicate
classical messages
but the message is they communicate can
depend on their entanglement so they can
they have entanglement they can perform
some measurements on the sentences and
based on that they can send a classical
answer
so as long as they're interaction is
classical potential entitlement
and note that there's something there's
a very important teleportation protocol
you know if you have unlimited qubits of
quantum communication you can simulate
that yourself
consumption this also encapsulates the
ability to send a limited number of
qubits
Alaska points
so much
yeah that's a great question so actually
um some of these the works I mentioned
in the previous head they actually imply
that you can get something like three or
two times login versus n to the one
minus one over K but uh
maybe maybe
a large constant times okay
but we suspect that you know we can
obtain such separation using fewer
number of rounds in the quantum protocol
and there are some things that can be
included
so we suspect that you can achieve
something like this with a certain
number of nouns
and questions
if not uh thanks Uma and all the
speakers of the session
so we have a brief coffee break outside
and we'll recall